Let's look at the answer to our simple
barrier quiz where we had this program where both
threads are going to synchronize on a single barrier and
then thread one finishes and then thread zero continues
alone. The question is does a simple barrier implementation
work for that? And the answer is yes, it
does work. If we only do this barrier once,
then the first thread that enters this critical section
will set the release to zero and increment
the count to one. The second thread that reaches
this will increment the count to two. If
the first thread ends up waiting for release, the
second one will still see that the count
is two, reset the count, set the release and
eventually due to coherence. Remember that coherence guarantees that
when we read the release eventually we'll see it,
it's just that we can be arbitrarily delayed. But
no matter how long we are delayed eventually we see
it, and there is no way to get stuck here.
So the thread that does the releasing leaves the barrier,
that release leaves the barrier. Or it might happen
that both of them execute this in very close proximity
to each other, both of them now see the new
count of two, and then both of them release and
exit the barrier. Either way, nobody gets stuck.
The reason why the simpler barrier is not entirely
correct is not that it doesn't work on the
first try, it's that it's not reusable. So the
problem occurs if we try to use this
barrier again after the first time we use it.
In which case, somebody might be stuck still here
and we reset this so that they never leave
the first instance while everybody else is in the second instance. But unless
we have that second instance of the barrier, this barrier works. So in this
particular case if we are sure that we are going to use this barrier only
once in the entire run of the program then this barrier does work correctly.